bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
vidéo où on va tester ensemble le jeu tu
imagines si incroyable je bats vous
allez les formes parce que vous l'avez
inventé ça veut rien dire sa variété am
et fm monopoly l'a jamais eue d'une
partie auquel toutes les anglais ils ont
aussi ils ont inventé le foot si l'on
gagne coupe du monde de slam au cette
info est chiante
on est avec tom tom a garé co créateur
du jeu cause des réalisateurs ont fait
avec multiprise si vous connaissez pas
évidemment à l'échec et fait des
sketches prison d identité derrière
multiprise pardon à moi j'ai oublié par
contre moi je leur dis ouais moi c'est
aurélien prévu aurélien provoqué sa
qualif chaîne youtube personnes ça fait
les matins je t'appelle multiprise 2 kg
freddy gladieux qui fait dire à dieu
sait pas ce qui a fait ce bail
et à nice
salut c'est voilà à nice et aurélien ont
participé à des sessions de tests avec
tom et moi pour faire le jeu donc vous
connaissez les règles même si elles ont
peut-être un peu changé depuis
je sais plus si ça a changé tout ce qui
peut du coup on va ou pas expliqué les
règles a prédit le jeu se compose en
trois manches la première manche va
consister à découvrir une carte
t'imagines si qui va nous plonger dans
une situation plus berlue et mme
boostant flanc est en fait il faudra
avec sa choisir dans cinq cartes qu'on
aura en main l'action qui nous paraît la
plus susceptible d'arriver dans la
situation assez les cartes actions qu'on
aura en main c'est les cartes bas il ya
en plus un arbitre qui changent à chaque
tour et celle arbitre qui donne le point
donc c'est à lui c'est lui qu'il faut
convaincre un peu comme dans d'autres
jeux dont on ça peut inspirer pour c'est
bien mais c'est pas du tout la même
chose
rien à voir le but du jeu c'est ce qu'on
a dit ce qui est écrit sur la boîte
c'est de faire de la mauvaise foi d'être
halde être marrant d'être drôle faut
vraiment amis inventif drôle trash
intelligent tous les moyens sont bons
pour gagner mais l'esprit alors moi je
vous précise et ya plein de son mauvais
joueur et où moi c'est pas mon cas je
suis bon joueur mais trop 26 chiens je
veux pas gagner je veux absolument
perdre je suis bon perdant en fait ça
que j'aurais bien pour l'avoir manche
pour pas le jeu on va distribuer 5
cartes bas donc cinq arrêts pour
imprégner
merci là on prend connaissance de nos
cartes pousser une version test ou les
photos sont définitives à nice tu
regardes et tu recules arbitres pour ce
tour c'est toi qui va tirer une carte
images ici quand vous l'avenir
d'accord les vous devez unir à chacun
d'être une carte qu'on a un petit temps
de réflexion
on joue chacun notre carte et après la
dislocation n'est sûr pourquoi tu as
joué ça a à peine questionner bien sûr
que c'est paniquant la carte une à
convaincre les identifications lubitsch
peut aussi dire
justification a choisi exactement tout
d'avoir l'arbitrage fut par tu peux
aisément si c'est de la merde arrête de
parler tu imagines si on était immortel
bah moi j'arrêterai de donner de
l'argent que le chat assez chacun autour
je sais quand on devrait ouais d'accord
ok oui donc si on était immortel
ouais il y aurait plus jamais de guerre
tout le monde se mettre sous la main je
poursuis ont été mortels je le mettrais
le roller pourquoi tu en veux mais aussi
parce que je pense que le zouk on peut
pas passer à côté tôt ou tard on zoome
ce faire on les oublie moi chérie la
deux fois deux fois de suite j'ai failli
jeter dit j'ai pas le temps alors que je
sais que si tu es mortels mais tu tombes
de danser sur le salaire forcément c'est
sûr et certain que j'ai choisi freddy
t'imagines si on pouvait voler les paye
moi je me tiendrai au hockey ça se tient
moi je pense qu'on sera tous chauds
ouais je pense à ce serait super man ou
les trop ben moi j'ai fait comme un
perroquet alors pourquoi on se sentirait
tout chaud bah on serait tout chaud
parce que du coup pendant qu'on vole il
y aurait beaucoup de frictions sur le
grade sa chaleur et la dilatation
des vaisseaux et c'est pas bon pour le
cuir chevelu avec l'évolution biologique
ont presque tous ceux qui n'ont pas de
cheveux est allé plus vite que ceux qui
ont des cheveux et du coup de fil en
aiguille on aurait demandé moins de
chance que tu continues moins quatre ans
de gagner non je pense à s'injecter
depuis longtemps alors que les
supplications pour les roubaisiens à
court d'iphone paraît simple et logique
parce que du coup si tout n'était en
l'air ça va quand même beaucoup de gens
dans ciels notamment apparue le temps
elle s'est couvert il y aurait des
collisions certaine elle fait d'être
roux par exemple il est beaucoup plus du
laurens est sûre d'elle frappé personne
en volant quoi et on sait la sécurité
moi je la bats sécuritaire entre
t'imagines si on pouvait voler
j'achèterais un perroquet bah oui sur
terre tu as des chiens évoqué la
compagnie yayi le lien logique mais
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur vous
voulez peut-être je tiens moi ça
sentirait ce fait un bond dans le métro
et là vous vous dites parce que tout le
monde va voler du coup dans le métro il
ya moins de gens c'est pas du tout ça
c'est juste parce que en fait système
malgré le fait que je pense qu'il ya des
dix oiseaux plus approprié qui vole plus
c'est pas le meilleur choix d'oiseaux
mais toutefois je mets dans les yeux un
peu gêné tu imagines si le cannibalisme
était super tendance alors c'est marrant
c'est un épisode qui est sorti il ya
quelques jours avec les eaux de la chine
partie biologique vous conseille de le
voir soulèvent pas vu le lien dans la
description
moi je ne ferais que j'ai fait le visage
de nicolas sketch est ce qu'après avoir
une autre je t'ai fait ben oui y'a trois
manches sont confinés non je veux dire
est ce qu'on va finir ces cas ouais
ouais bah l'apprendra plus chaud plus on
avance en plus c'est dur je garderai la
braguette ouverte tout le temps tu sais
jamais quoi est-ce qu'on parlerait tout
simplement on devient prêtre en jeu
deviendra peut être top pourquoi tu te
ferai pas de visage
presque parce que six games était hyper
cool on a un petit peu envie de bouffer
tout le monde ce serait un peu dangereux
quelqu'un et je pense que personne de
maman d'orange de croquer dans nos
assiettes
donc encore une fois je pense la
sécurité je suis un peu le beau rigail
sécu du groupe mais ça me protégerait
pas mal de me faire croquer à nice par
gédéon parlerai tout simplement pourquoi
parce que alors et une grosse vague de
films des années 40 50 sur le
cannibalisme et du coup en fait ces
films là lui qui a une grosse période où
le cannibalisme n'était pas à la mode
c'est à dire des adeptes de maintenant
j'ai fin des années 40 jusqu'à ma
vraiment désolé et bah on se dirait
[ __ ] ses films des années 40 allemand
il était cool en fait c'étaient les
traits que ça c'est pas lequel est pas
lisse me devient légal ou toléré lille
d'intendance un peu plus tôt les veines
mais ça reste quand même un truc un peu
un péché de l'an denier même et du coup
il ya eu 90 catholique qui voudraient
aller se confesser
il faut penser aux pauvres prêtres qui
sont acquis guerre diront des journées
un peu binaire du coup comme ça j'ai
paul ray les autres presse parce que tu
es férié il savait de confession 24 7
jours sur 7
même le dimanche 7 juin je garderai ma
braguette ouverte tout le temps cela
fait dans l'espoir que les cannibales et
une mauvaise dentition
[Rires]
oui donc là où la marque on a tous une
carte bas ok donc pas ce qui se passe
c'est que pour ce tour il ya plus
d'arbitrés
on va tous mettre notre carte bas on va
tout jouer en même temps et du coup on
va devoir voter à la fin pour qui on
donne le point ne peut juste pas voter
pour soi ok ça va ok si tu as bien
auquel tu imagines si tout le monde
était chaud je donnerai tout ma formule
la scientologie
je ferai une poupée confères de mon père
on aurait tous très mauvaise haleine
je m'inscrivais on s'est appelé qu'au
fur cela deviendrait des étages qui se
lance en premier
ma fortune à la scientologie parce que
pour l'instant j'ai hyper envie de le
faire tu vois mais comme je garde la
thune pour
un plan tu vois j'ai besoin de cet
argent particulièrement toulon les
choses on voit ce budget il directement
alloués la scientologie tu t'es bien
organisés sont en outre officialisé
si on perd
moi je commence par en perdre son rêve
avec mon père il n'aime pas du tout les
mecs qui sont chauds du coup bah je
trouverais poupée gonflable avec mme
merkel des cheveux comme ça vous plaît
pour s amuser avec papa je t'aime très
fort fait donc du coup moi je pense que
l'on aurait besoin mais hélène parce que
si on était tous au havre on aurait pu
besoin de shampoing évidemment
du coup on aurait pu faire les courses
on serait des prix mais on n'est jamais
au supermarché pas ça nous rappelle
qu'on est tout seul avait du coup plus
dentifrice plus gros ça donc on n'a pas
du tout faisant lâcher déjà qu'à manger
beaucoup de cyrus moi je suis dans un
monde où il ya pas de produits
alimentaires dans les supermarchés
donc je noie hockey soyons son truc
chacun son image ici moi je deviens de
l'état rien alors on s'en fou pour
cordes qui est marrant c'est que j'avais
cette carte je deviendrai l'état rien et
j'aurais pu utiliser tout à l'heure
quand le truc c'était si on était
cannibale sa collègue parfaite moyen est
gelée parfaite donc moi je trouve ça
marrant et moi si on était tous chauds
mais je m'inscrirai ont sapé coiffure
pourquoi voir pourquoi j'ai pour toi
pour toucher la bourse
1 2 3
du coup c'est un rêve se réalise deux
choix au hasard
t'imagines si on caire a tant aimé là on
a plus de bah non c'est pour ça dans
franc de buff j'ai pris le racing
ça va être assez nucci bouton et je vous
laisse lire c'est pour nous t'imagines
si la masturbation était payante genre
20 euros pourquoi comme les gens lisent
aura plus de budget je serai budget par
la plus bue jet pour aller au cabab et
bah du coup je serai tranquille dans mon
cas box qui serait en train de louer
leurs budgets restauration à
l'instauration à nice qui est ce qu'il
ya de salut aux orgasmique sur terre que
des frites à volonté
franchement des frites à volonté c'est
pas une érection jeunesse et les légumes
à holroyd l'ailé des oui mais avec le
bail des frites quoi
le géant lui voter pour aucun d'entre
eux n'a obligé je vois je sortais avec
froid de 1o ça va donc la mère mal et si
j'ai bien compris on passe la deuxième
manche face à la deuxième manche
freddy la manche de son m'attirer un
imagine si et on va devoir imaginer la
meilleure carte bas possible ok donc là
c'est on imagine ce que je sais que 104
s'imagine si c'était bien vu de péter le
duc ou bien entendu je décide du temps
tirosh me dire c'est l'histoire de suite
et c'est là un exemple mais je vais vous
laisser encore de temps et quand la 3e
d'hygiène pour mettre la pression aux
autres j'ai moi aussi j'ai ok c'est quoi
ton jeu très mais vraiment encore plus
avec cyrus avait alors c'est alors t'as
pas honte à toi et toi tu te dis c'est
quoi ce qu'est vraiment avait l'air
d'avoir bien je pense qu'on dira au
resto il ya des haricots avant on aurait
dit maintenant je prends pas s'il ya des
écoles maintenant aux hellènes
moi je prends vu que c'est bien vu en
société fréry et l'effort vas-y tu as
l'air d'avoir moi je pense il faudrait
annoncer avant de péter tu adores gvt et
péter parce que sinon tu es un gameplay
très efficace et moi kebede et ont volé
les peines des autres cela je pense
qu'il ya des vidéos z8 à perte qui
serait beaucoup moins drôle c'est lui
qui donne maintenant je vous rappelle
que je fais partie des c'est le co
créateur du jeu de tête qui l'a déjà les
réponses à l'aps je considère que c'est
un demi point il ya tellement de
combinaisons possibles j'étais vrai
qu'on n'est jamais tombé sur la même je
crois hélas bien souvent les gens de ce
site qu'il y en a qui vont pas aimer les
mêmes choses
c'est un jour vraiment possibilités
y'a pas encore moi je suis un seul mois
le faire signer sa part être je fais
comme ça il apparaître contre eux mais
de droit je peux aussi fait ça il
apparaîtra sur ton front
oui je peux essayer de mettre le prix la
moue sur mon coin je veux mettre un
gagneur suisse jacqueline matin merci si
rudy demotte et un frère merci ça si je
peux voir les yeux bleus ne bouge pas il
est peut être la double mais faut pas
qu'il vous sinon c'est chiant je vois
plus la vidéo c'est qu'ils ont été
enlevés là c'est bon tu t'imagines si ya
pas encore du générique meilleur alors
ça c'est quand il applaudit de la
débrouille canard de plus un nom il a
mis trop d fixe donc à petit dans ses
buts bateau juste avant l'audience ses
gardes
[Rires]
t'imagines si notre nez était notre
organe sexuel auquel je l'est où j'ai
pour toi à ton adige et ouais obbadi
lance ok mais pas moi mais lens aurait
du coup quand les eskimos wsk à des gros
baiser à nice n'en attend pour la fin
c'est vraiment lui tient du coup si luce
bon ce serait beaucoup plus souvent dans
le gros veut dire non ah oui du coup ben
moi je pense que gérard depardieu sera
en croire pour l'instant j'aime beaucoup
la proposition de cyrus il reste la vàd
réponse s'il n'est était un organe
sexuel sur les sites de cul pour les de
cliquer sur big block jeu j'ai créé sur
big italienne aux il y aurait plein
d'italiens comme ça avec des grands quai
et on passe à la manche 3 alors la
manche 3 en gros c'est l' inverse on va
prendre
une carte bas une carte conséquences et
on va devoir imaginer le meilleur tu
imagines si qui va franchement vous
voulez pas en face aux tempos plutôt on
se méfierait vachement plus des
grands-mères et là vous devez donc
trouver le t'imagines chi chi et jay jay
qui est la cause de ceux de cette phrase
j'ai c'est combien de temps aurélien ça
t'imagines si hitler c'était une grand
mère aucun magistrat dit moi c'était
t'imagines si mussolini
imagine si toutes les grands-mères
ressembler à vis à thomas tom non moi
c'était t'imagines si les caches où ça
s'était fait à partir de la base de la
drogue du violeur par exemple quand même
une grand-mère était fait ouais je vais
coiffe tous un cerveau c'est différent
rockets allez je vais donner en venir
d'art question dernier tour de cette
partie en flammes et aux filles auraient
une pénurie de sopalin j'ai t'imagines
si avait un attentat meurtrier dans la
région d'arcachon t'imagines si le
sopalin c'était du beurre au revoir à la
mairie de pénurie nous laver t'imagines
si on avait tous un toc qui était chaque
jour de devoir arracher millefeuille ne
sont pas là en se levant du coup il y
aura une pénurie
très rapidement que sur place ne savais
pas j'imagine si un gars voulaient
gagner encore et se seraient tentés de
reproduire à
à échelle 1 0 genre la planète
abbas de sopalin du coup le gars il
ferait ou l asie la ch mon grand il
achetait pense qu'il est ultra geek
lâché plein plan global et la baisse
avant l'asie
du coup il y aurait pourtant de dire
alors que nul le coup et terrorisme
d'arcachon sa main ouais ouais c'est
vrai tu sais ce que je ne sais pas mais
pas du tout façon c'est le musée de ce
marché sont regardés voilà je suis agent
avec franck est plus d'arcachon vous
avez raison les verts dijon alors ces
jeunes je rappelle à bon compte des
points que c'est pas un jeu où on est je
vous non plus pour forcément avoir des
points mais le but c'est de passer un
bon moment si deux des curieux c'est
apprendre des choses j'ai de moi parce
que j'ai pas assez de ponts pour gagner
mais je vais vous dire combien pareil
moi je suis dégoûté j'ai trois points
mais plus que ces russes m'ont attrapé
trois de moins que rien
après tant d'efforts moi je vais faire
briller un peu freiné ou pour 565 ouais
ok ouais bah oui je pense qu'il ya six
ans mais s'il est poussé les bois
écoutez bravo et merci beaucoup les gars
merci d'être venus merci des nominations
les gars merci les gars d'équipé vous
avez cliqué visas non mais vraiment je
lui dirai évidemment parce que on est
bien sûr le truc qu'on doit créer dès
l'aller puis surtout content qu'on fait
parfois non chez vous chez vous à la
maison que vous pouvez jouer en savaient
pas obligé de jouer tous comme ça je
dois regarder à
c'est encore mieux eh ben c'est pas
parce qu'on est des vidéos marrantes que
l'on joue bien j'ai joué que mes
grands-parents il était très fort si les
vins que dieu vous n'avez pas encore
fait votre cadeau pour noël pourquoi 28
ans et ça ça le jeu et le lien pour
l'acheter dans description et ouais
merci on a déjà eu des retours gens qui
ont acheté le jeu ça fait plaisir ça
plaisait deviendra description ou
possibles autres confits zik chez des
libraires chez
l'ags la fnac abonnés mois multi prises
d'abonné oui et j'ai même cliquer sur la
cloche les blues les risques à wake sera
bonne et j'ai tenté lot mais j'ai bien
tu aimes bien sûr devait avoir une
phrase de fin pour cette vidéo ça sera
laquelle passeraient joyeux noël et
bonne fête
bonne fête de ces dames ici là et là ils
sont que sa main là il se demande d'où
pression de vos proches
ça lui a fait du bien aussi